le livre lui est dédié il est dédié à
laurent évrard qu'est libraire à tour
avec martin arnold etienne la librairie
le livre voilà laurent évrard est un des
deux associés de la librairie
tourangelle le livre des libraires qui
accompagne avec viard le lauréat du
goncourt depuis son premier ouvrage une
histoire d'amitié de près de 20 ans et
la découverte d'un auteur remarquable
depuis le début qu'elle que soit voilà
c'est quelqu'un qui reste d'une
intégrité d'une d'une ferveur et d'une
générosité
voilà pareil je ne changera pas et
d'ailleurs le match qui nous a rendus
j'en étais jeune était très très touché
enfin martin mon collègue aussi parce
que c'est aussi la marque d'un homme
d'une fidélité d'une amitié dans
l'accompagnement un accompagnement suivi
d'un engagement avec la coédition de
deux livres a dit rick viard en 2012 on
avait décidé pour ses deux premiers
livres dont qui sont chez actes sud qui
sont congo les batailles d'occident de
faire une coédition c'est à dire que
l'engagement d'un engagement et et
financiers c'est à dire voilà on achète
300 exemplaires de chacun des titres en
liga pour le faire découvrir
donc on avait fait un de couverture qui
nous appartiennent enfin qui n'était que
pour la librairie l'audience je trouve
ça important cet engagement là à dire
que c'est pas simplement le liban le
travail
josé libanais pas simplement d'être
l'écho ou la résonance du marché c'est
vraiment faire des choix esthétiques
intellectuelle et politique
eric vuillard était déjà venue en mai
dernier rencontrer ses lecteurs pour
l'ordre du jour le goncourt a été une
vraie surprise tous très très très
heureux pour lui très heureux pour la
littérature et pour les lecteurs
parce qu'ils vont avoir à faire un
véritable écrivain et découvre une
oeuvre de la littérature qui vont les
engagés dans un mouvement lire c'est
toujours à un rapport d'expérience le
goncourt va offrir une nouvelle
notoriété avec vuillard que la librairie
de livres continuera d'accompagner